When you think that an employee spends more time at work than with his family,...
...you realize that building good relationships is absolutely necessary.
Getting along with your co-workers might seem like a huge effort, but the benefits can be great.
Here are some basics.
First, a simple greeting can be most effective, and being cheerful helps you and others.
It is best not to get involved in office politics or to associate with cliques.
It will likely be counterproductive and can backfire on you.
Second, if you work on a project, make sure you do your part.
Never let others do the bulk of your work.
Third, praising and complimenting a co-worker for a good idea or a job well done will go a long way.
You should give constructive criticism at a proper time and in private,...
...rather than mentioning mistakes and shortcomings in front of the boss or the team.
Lastly, getting involved in gossip is a waste of time.
Avoid talking to a colleague about another co-worker.
It's best to change the subject, because it's not really your business.